hello and welcome to this video playing
FM louts notes
okay one two time saying in some already
interesting I don't remember I can't but
it can be like some some random bullet
game or something okay so when it's
transposing to ad for style of opening
you know it's uh interest an interesting
line knight c6 it's what they usually do
know which was posed into our classical
kings in you what do you probably both
more so good
yeah so black um just handed me the
payoff bishops maybe trying to get some
counterplay when the Queen side yeah it
might work that taking a and b5 I could
take with them with the ebon dough
huh I'm not quite in time there if I
take with the pond probably age three
was too superficial at a crook c8 I
would like to play b3 but then it's
gotta be five and my c3 Knight is
hanging I can't do this and then play
Queen b3 I'm trying this I'm trying this
I mean and it's not well okay rook c8 is
the most natural move ever but if it
doesn't do it immediately I have the
time maybe to play b3 okay I don't get
the stumped
I quit b3 there is Queen to c7 wow that
was very stupidly played okay well Queen
c7 I've got Bishop to b6 okay not such a
big deal
okay so he will probably play 97-95
I need you to this kind of thing anyway
and I can get the Queen to a3 the
long-term idea is that black structure
somewhat inferior with the porn being
backward only seven I cook one Bishop f1
looking at the e7 pawn and I might also
set this Queen side in motion but before
at the later stage yeah I'm happy to go
here I'm now have before c5 on the cards
there'll be 45 I would be quite noise
yeah that move is insane I'm sorry
what are you doing they're trying to
weaken everything that you have that
doesn't work so now I just have to
attack Fon the drops right between to be
one
now that can't work
see five was also a good move but I just
get informed or nothing okay
hmm it might even work it's a bit it's a
bit weird but I don't think I could have
taken it like Juan takes pawn takes
Bishop d3 27 and I have no way to
protect air 3 that's really remarkable
ok Queen d7 is he going to f4 ok well
let's take this first now use the
majority threatening c6 ok it doesn't
attack anything right
I could go Queen is 6 and then c6 and
then before his hanging probably just c6
now gone dead one card it was just not a
good position in the first place
ff5 is really a bit crazy I mean this
this is a Felton not too bad well the
engine totally hates black opposition
interesting I didn't feel it was so
terrible really
okay boy castles castles be should be
three or completely normal
and the engine wants to go f4 here wow
it's not a it's a pretty low depth of
analysis so not taking this too serious
too seriously F warm well yeah maybe
maybe you can do it h3 has been a bit
lame I am completely willing to admit
that and now I took with the pawn yeah I
didn't think that this is so great
because of b5 and then the knight
jumping to c4 after you could see a
doesn't make or make some sense so this
one Queen c7 I got this Bishop d6 with
this is this is a good position for
white I mean White has more space the e
pawn is a problem I've got the bishop
pair then that adds up went here on 295
and I'm really happy here I've got
before coming oh it's got 93 oh wow that
completely ignored that move I think I
was too relaxed there Sabine's being so
happy with my situation I should
probably just go back to C 2 or D 1 the
engine wants to go here after cover d3
instead of that he claimed f5 which is
yeah I mean that is and then a mistake
in two ways with 93 he would have been
fine and f5 this is just just a crazy
move
I completely did not see 93 again he I
simply did not register to me that he
can go to d3 which is again a move and
said he went to Evo and then he's lost
and we both had a complete blind spot
down somehow but I should play as f4 it
seems probably because after this roopd
one year this No
oopsie true threatening before and the
night has no squares okay and now it's
just over there was a cool move that was
a cool move I thought I cannot take the
engine does not agree because it's his
Bishop d1 and then Queenie form yeah
this is a big of a problem right I
cannot take a cover it this is losing
immediately
it seems that Bishop d1 is refuting it
like this this and now Quinn g6 okay
but King edge one is good yeah I mean
there's just no way for him to say
before and if that drops the whole
position falls apart just system just a
disaster but we both completely did not
see that there was 93 that's funny it's
a very very basic thing but we didn't
see it okay guys thanks for watching